STARTED FOR OUR BRIEF.
SCHEDULED BMP AT HEARING WE
NOTICE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM BUT
PRESENCE OF FELLOW REPUBLICANS
HERE AS WELL SO WE WILL GET
STARTED WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE IT IS AB TWENTY A AB TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN BY.
SUMMERS THERE AND WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES FOR TAKING TIME
OUT OF A BUSY DAY TO TAKE HERE
THIS BILL --
AB TWELVE FORTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
IS TO RECEIVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY.
TRAINING FOR SERVING PATIENTS
WITH A AND WITHIN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IN ADDITION I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS
BILL.
OF PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY IS
PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES TO
SENIORS AND PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND THAT WHY DON'T I STOP THERE
AND HAVE --
JOE MICHAEL --
DO SOME SOME COMMUNICATING AS
WELL.
I DON'T THINK JOE IS HERE YET
BUT OKAY JERRY DESMOND WITH
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA P.
FACT.
AND THE LICENSEE POPULATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL NEVER PROUD
TO BE UP IN SUPPORT OF A MEASURE
THAT BROUGHT FIVE FOR LGBT
COMPETENCY BOTH AN ORIGINAL
EDUCATION AS WELL AS CONTINUING
EDUCATION FOR OUR LICENSES.
AND WERE UP PLEASE BE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
IS SUPPORT.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS TIME I
SING THEN LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MUSIC TYPICAL.
LOW HERE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BLOOM CHINA [inaudible]
JILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG.
GIPSON HERE GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
TING.
OKAY ANOTHER ESTO SQUIRM.
AND WILL IS THERE A MOTION SO
MORE [inaudible]
OKAY MOTIONS.
I RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IF A PLEASE CALL THEM.
SENATE MINUTES TO BE CONCURRED
AND BLOW BY.
BLOW EYEBROW ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN FONG.
FONG UP VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON NOT VOTING [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE.
ABILITY NOW TING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
THEY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF IN
FACT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT NAM OF
TO I'M FOR WHICH IS S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE BY CENTER
CANNELLA.
SENATE CANNELLA WELCOME
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SHARE MEMBERS REPRESENTING S. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN I WHICH ALLOWS
FOR THE HOLDER OF A TEMPORARY
LICENSE FOR CANNABIS CULTIVATION
TO APPLY FOR A PROVISIONAL.
ANNUAL LICENSE VALID FOR TWELVE
MONTHS UNTIL THEIR GROUND
GRANTED OR DENIED NON TEMPORARY
LICENSE.
THE SUNSET DAYTON THE MEDICINAL
AND I DON'T USE CANNABIS
REGULATION SAFETY ACT STATES
THAT TEMPORARY LICENSE WILL NO
LONGER BE ISSUED AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
WHAT THE RELEASE OF THE NEW
DRAFT AMENDMENTS COUNTIES WERE
ALSO NOTIFY THE STATE WILL NO
LONGER ISSUE EXTENSIONS TO
PREVIOUSLY ISSUED TEMPORARY
LICENSES?
THE BUREAU OF CANVASSING CONTROL
HAD ORIGINALLY INFORMED COUNTIES
THAT APPLICATION WITH PENDINE
FOR THE ANSWER --
FOR THE ANSWER TO THE STATUS OF
ANNUAL LICENSE APPLICATIONS WAS
SUFFICIENT FOR ISSUING
EXTENSIONS.
WITHOUT ACTION BY THE STATE
LOCAL BUSINESSES THAT COUNTIES
ALLOWED OPERATE UNDER PRIOR
REGULATIONS WHILE THEY'RE
PERMITS WILL BE A PROCESS WILL
HAVE TO STOP OPERATIONS AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
AND ALSO LIKE TO THANK ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ASSISTED IN
DRAFTING THIS LEGISLATION
LEGISLATIVE SOLUTION TO PREVENT
A DISRUPTION.
IN AN INFANT LEGAL MARKET IN
HALTING OF MUCH NEEDED TAX
REVENUES.
LIKE TO WELCOME CARE MORTENSEN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES OF PAUL
SMITH WITH THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES GIVE YOU MORE
BACKGROUND ANSWER QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING CARE MARTIN'S AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
JUST VERY BRIEFLY --
THIS BILL IS A WORKABLE APPROACH
TO LIFE.
THE LICENSE GAP THAT WE ARE
GOING TO SOON APPROACH COME THE
END OF THE YEAR WE ESSENTIALLY
HAVE A DUAL LICENSING SYSTEM FOR
COMMERCIAL CANNABIS ACTIVITY IN.
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SUCH AS HUMBOLDT COUNTY SANTA
BARBARA ON MONTEREY AND OTHERS
THAT ARE EVEN SEES ME WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE LOCAL
PROCESS INCLUDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS --
ARE TAKING A LITTLE BIT LONGER
THAN EXPECTED AND THIS WILL HELP
KEEP BUSINESSES WITHIN THE
REGULATED MARKETPLACE AND ALLOW
ADDITIONAL TIME AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR REVIEW.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL
SMITH WITH THE RURAL COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION ECHO EVERYTHING IS
MARTINSON SAID JUST NOTE THAT IF
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING LIKE THIS
IN THIS KIND OF URGENT MANNER
WHERE WE FACE POTENTIAL OF
SEEING A LOT OF FOLKS WOULD WANT
TO COME INTO THE LEGAL MARKET --
COMING OUT IN AND STAYING OUT
FOR A VERY LONG TIME SO THIS IS
A VERY CRITICAL BILL.
PARTICULAR FOR CULTIVATING
COUNTIES TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
KEEP -- A
SYSTEM IN CHECK --
AND HAVE A POTENTIAL INDUSTRY
THAT IS YOU KNOW REGULATED --
AND LEGAL --
AND SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN WORK WITH SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE URGENCY OF
THIS BILL AND THANK ALL OF THOSE
THAT HAVE SPENT A LOT OF HOURS
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS
TRYING TO GET THIS MEASURE UP
PUT TOGETHER AND AN URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE NAME
INFLATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO I
CAN MORNING KAREN LAYING ON TOP
OF THE HUMBOLDT COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SO THANKFUL TO THE
SENATOR FOR INCLUDING US ASKARI
AYE VOTE.
GOOD MEDICARE ALSO BEHALF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
SURE MEMBERS GRANT MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG COOLEY BEEN STRONG
SUPPORTERS IMPORTANT HEALTH
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CAN MEET ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
CAREERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE DROP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CLIFF
BURKE HEARING BEHALF SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY AND I WANT TO
THANK C. SACK FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IN THE AUTHOR FOR CARING
GET.
A WE SUPPORT SEE SACKS EFFORT
HERE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
BEVERLY YOU ON BEHALF YOU W.
ASKS ME LOCAL THREE NINE THIRTY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL
THINK.
JENNIFER COMPUTER LOW I'M BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF MINOR AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AIR NOTE ON BEHALF
OF THE CAN OF SUSPICION
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
TONY BROWN HALF OF RIVER
DISTURBING YOUR SUPPORT.
JASON BRIGHT CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT WHAT THE
CANCER DOING THIS BILL PRICHARD
OFFERS LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AMY JENKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
AND CALCRAFT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MAX DOUGLAS ON
BEHALF OF FLOW KANA AND CAL FOR
CAMPUS DELIVERY LICENSE SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
TINO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTION [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OPEN.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CENTER
SO I WAS A SUPPORTER OF THE
CONTENTS OF THE BILL BEFORE WAS
AMENDED IT WAS JUST IN THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS GOTTEN AMENDED WITH
THIS LANGUAGE WHICH IS ALWAYS A
FRUSTRATION FOR ME AND I KNOW
SOMETIMES IT'S NECESSARY.
WONDERING THAT THIS A PROBLEM
THAT'S BEEN BREWING FOR AWHILE
WHY WAS IT NECESSARY TO LIE TO
TAKE THIS ISSUE UP SO LATE.
WELL YEAH JUST WATCH MY TENSION
A COUPLE DAYS AGO WHICH IS WHY I
AMENDED BY BILL.
WAS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WAS AN
INTERPRETATION AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS.
THAT THEY COULD IF THEIR
APPLICATION WAS PENDING THEY
COULD CONTINUE OPERATING WHAT
CAME OUT WITH THE OF A NEW
THOUGHT THAT THAT DOES NOT
COUNTY MORE.
WHICH CREATED THIS PROBLEM THAT
I'M TRYING TO ADDRESS NOW
[inaudible]
WELL ON IT'S FRUSTRATING FOR ME
BUT I'LL SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE I AM [inaudible]
FRUSTRATE RETAIL.
COULD YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CAMINO.
SEEING NONE --
CENTER CANNELLA TO WISH TO CLOSE
MY SUBSCRIBER THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THREE
SEPARATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS THE PAST LOW LIGHT BLUE
EYED BROWN.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BIGGER I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG AYE GIPSON AYE AYE GIPSON
AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
AYE TING [inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS FIFTEEN VOTES EMILY THE
ROLE OPEN FOR AFTER MEMBERS.
A MEMBERS NOW -
FOR FI ITEM NUMBER TWO AND THREE
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTS IN THE
PHONE BILLS ARE REPORTED BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO CONCUR AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS AGAIN THAT'S
FILE ITEM. TO AB THIRTY ONE
FORTY THREE AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
FOUR I HEARING NO OBJECTION
THOSE BILLS WILL BE REPORTED TO
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
SO HERE NONE THERE WE GO --
AND THERE THEY'RE FOR THEN THE
SECRETARY WILL JUST GO THROUGH
THE WILL THEN AGAIN FOR A FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE AND FOR SO.
AGAIN --
RESEARCHING FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN AB TWELVE
FORTY SEVEN SEVEN MINUTES WE
CONCURRED AND PRO [inaudible]
ONE BROWN OUT [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
WHEN MY [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GRAYSON.
REYES AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I OKAY AT TWELVE THE TO
THE BILL IS OUT AND THEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS S. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE MUCH AS THE
PAST ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
GIVE IT.
THE BILL HAS A FIFTEEN VOTES.
AND WE WILL LEAVE THE THE ROLE
OF THE TRAPS MEMBERS WILL --
STILL SAY OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
TWO MINUTES FOR MEMBERS TO AT
FIVE I ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN SENATE EVENT
SPEAK TO BE COULD HURT AND
ARAMBULA.
RAM THE HIGH.
AND THEN FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
S. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN MOTION HAS THE
PAST ARAMBULA.
REBEL AYE IRWIN [inaudible]
FUNDAMENTAL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IRWIN NOW.
THE BACK TO FILE ITEM OF ONE THE
BEEF TWELVE FORTY SEVEN THIS
AREA.
SENATE TO BE CONCURRED AND IRWIN
[inaudible]
BERMAN I OF VIOLENT ONE AGAIN
AB.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN CENTER
MINISTRY CAN HURT AND HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE
.
FATHER BEFORE SP.
FOURTEEN FIFTY MOTIONS TO PASS
HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I
WE HAVE REFERENCE AYE
VOTE THEM FILE ITEM NUMBER WHEN
YOU BE.
TWELVE FORTY SEVEN SENATE
MINUTES SPEAKING HEARD AND
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I..
GAYS SIXTEEN INTO THE BILL IS
OUT AND FILE A NUMBER FOR S. B..
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE MOTIONS TO
PASS CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I THE EIGHTEEN TO ONE
AND THAT BILL IS UP [inaudible]
VERY ADJOURNED